i used to be very much like this like
hey i need a plan i want to know exactly
what i'll map out in xyz and then i had
this amazing mentor and he used to tell
me christian people like you always
think there's one way to roam and then
you realize you don't even want to be in
rome
how do you get started on thinking about
the science of look as far as i was
aware look with some random chance
blessed to some and not to others and
the end of a rainbow and a pot of gold
and stuff like that why does the signs
have look come into it
yeah that's a great question because you
know we always assume that luck is
something that just happens to us right
so you know being born into a nice
family stuff like that that we can't
really influence um what i found
fascinating both in my work as
entrepreneur social entrepreneur but
also in my research is that somehow the
most successful inspiring people they
seem to have in common that they somehow
intuitively cultivate a little bit more
luck than others and so i got fascinated
by that question is there some kind of
smart luck here is there's some kind of
process we can influence so take the
example right imagine you have erratic
hand movements like i do and you then
you spill a lot of coffee and so imagine
you spill coffee in a coffee shop over
someone and they look at you slightly
annoyedly but you sense there might be
something there you don't know what it
is you just sense there might be
something there and now you have two
options right option number one is you
just say i'm so sorry here's a napkin
you walk outside and you think ah what
could have happened had i spoken with a
person option number two you speak with
a person that person turns out to become
the love your life or your co-founder or
you name it the point is our reaction to
the unexpected us making the accident
meaningful in a way creates that kind of
smart luck that kind of serendipity and
so in a way a lot of our research
focuses on the question is there a
pattern behind all these different
stories of serendipity is that always
the same process of some kind of
unexpected trigger happening but then us
connecting the dots and doing something
with it and so that's the fastest thing
we can create more of those triggers but
also we can learn how to connect those
dots better so is the difference between
look and serendipity whether it's random
or whether it's purposeful or
intentional
well it's interesting because in a way
both kind of the blind luck and the
smart luck which certainly is
somehow have some kind of randomness in
it right bumping into that person at a
conference or you know i'll tell you the
example of the of the potato washing
machine to to to to give you that uh
that point but the the idea is that that
there's always some kind of element of
randomness but then we have some kind of
agency in it we have some kind of
control over not the situation itself
but our response to it and so take the
potato washing machine right essentially
a couple of years ago um a company in
china they produce refrigerators washing
machines and so on and they receive
calls from farmers and the farmers told
them your crappy washing machine is
always breaking down well why is the
washing machine breaking down well we're
trying to wash our potatoes and it
doesn't seem to work so what we usually
do we'll probably tell them well don't
wash your potatoes in the washing
machine like it's made for clothes you
know why would you do that they did the
opposite they said you know what that's
unexpected that's random but there's for
a lot of farmers in china who have a
similar problem so why don't we build in
a dirt filter and make it a potato
washing machine that's how
serendipitously so the potato washing
machine emerged that's how up to 50 of
innovations and inventions emerge that's
how a lot of times we fall in love it's
not only bumping into that person we
have to go on a date we have to do
something with it to actually turn it
into that kind of positive outcome that
doesn't just happen to us
it seems to me that there's two things
that we're playing with here one of them
being
how frequently we can put ourselves into
situations where the randomness can come
to us and then also our response to
those situations which is kind of how we
profit or benefit or make good of
whatever happens is that right
absolutely it's exactly it's kind of
like in a way making the accident
meaningful and
you know that's exciting having more
accidents having more accidents right
like we can literally create more
positive accidents
yeah that's interesting well i mean is
serendipity still serendipity if you
take an active role in it
well
you know that's the fascinating thing
right when people connect the dots at
hindsight when they look at their cv or
so they would say oh this was just lucky
there and this lucky here but then they
think about it they're like oh but
actually you know what i worked really
hard to have that luck i worked really
hard to then follow up with that
conference guy i bumped into and then do
this and do this and so the point here
is that actually when you look at
serendipity um and and the role of
people in it it's more than we we think
but we airbrush it out of our stories
right i work a lot with with um
executives and when you're the ceo of a
company you come into the boardroom and
you want to be able to say i planned
this i did this and then this happened
right
yeah everyone knows that you know what
like it's probably more like a squiggle
like like our cv right it's not just i
planned this i did this i did this no
like you bumped into someone and you did
this this this but and that's what i'm
so fascinated about this topic
it's instead of thinking oh this is weak
oh my god like i wasn't in control this
is actually the ultimate form of trying
to figure out how to gain some kind of
control over your environment and let go
of an illusion of control to say hey i
created a mindset and a culture that
allows actually for those unexpected
things to happen instead of actually
overlooking them right you would never
see the potato washing machine if you
would say no this doesn't fit my
marketing plan it shouldn't be here
yeah it doesn't happen and you will be
in control of your old plan but maybe
you'll be out of business in a few years
when there's so many farmers who
actually wanted that machine and your
competitor did it right and so it's
really these kind of things where it's
our control over over those kind of
things well you can't stop the
randomness that's going to continue to
happen so i think you're right getting
ready to control that it feels like the
sort of old-school business world where
everybody would have to wear a suit and
a tie and everybody have to work from
the office and everyone would have to be
very prim and proper i think that that
illusion of control
is kind of masking over the fact that
it's idiots all the way up i've got a
bunch of friends that i've met uh
and i've spent a bit of time with people
that are around literally the highest
echelons of tech and of business and a
finance and they've said to me dude
no one has an idea what they're doing
everyone is clueless the entire way up
all the way up and everyone's winging it
so
getting ourselves to this stage now
where you go okay look
the
veil has been lifted there is no magic
that's sort of going on here what we're
trying to do is create a culture or an
environment in which this randomness can
be profited on didn't you have a story
about
was it viagra as well
absolutely and you know to exactly your
point right that's the fascinating thing
that once you let go of this idea that
you can control everything then actually
you start building that muscle for the
unexpected and that decreases anxiety
you know i come from germany we love to
control things to plan things to to to
have a plan right and then real life
happens you're like oh my god like now
i'm overwhelmed versus if you're saying
you know what you know i i'll have a
plan now but i'm already building in the
the expectation that there will be
something unexpected and that's not the
threat that could actually be something
even more beautiful right and and we can
talk about other other examples there
for example viagra right viagra is
exactly this where researchers were
giving people medication against angina
pectoris the the the the illness and and
they realized unexpectedly there was
some kind of movement in male
participants trousers and you know what
we usually do we'll probably either try
to ignore it or kind of find a better
way to kind of you know get rid of that
side effect of of having that kind of
movement they did the opposite they said
you know what that's unexpected but
there's probably a lot of men in the
world who might have a problem with that
department so why don't we develop a
medication around this and that's really
the thing here right to exactly your
point that if we're trying to stick with
our original plan just focus on this we
don't see all these beautiful other
things that might come of it and that's
the same you know in any any part in
life and and
that's what what the excitement is i
think that that there's so many
meaningful potentialities out there but
but we have to open our eyes to it
how malleable or ingrained do you think
our people's
uh mindsets around luck
you know it's interesting because i
always thought you know people
like what i presume you from from what
i've seen myself and others who
intuitively cultivate a lot of
serendipity there you know i first
thought hey this content is for for
those people who then have vocabulary a
language for what they intuitively do it
legitimizes what they do and then kind
of they can go to their boss and say no
i wasn't out of control here i actually
created um something that allowed me to
to get here um and that works but but
then what's actually much more
fascinating to me is the second group of
people uh like a colleague of mine in
london uh you know this kind of eminent
professor type person wonderful person
but he came to me at the beginning when
i started this work and he said
christian i love you i love your work
but i don't need serendipity like i have
i have a nice family i have a nice job i
have everything i need like why would i
need this so we made a deal we said you
know what why do you not use a couple of
of strategies and we can talk about for
example the hook strategy which i which
i asked him to use and then um you know
ask a couple of different questions
couple of those things and then we'll
we'll reconvene in a couple of weeks he
comes back a couple of weeks after and
he's like christian i didn't know life
can be so joyful and and to me that's
really the kind of thing that those
people who believe that there's this
difference between luck and kind of hard
work those are the ones who once they
realize oh my god i can create my own
luck who get the most excited because
for them is the biggest shift versus for
others it's like yeah great i have
another exercise here but it's kind of a
more incremental shift and to give an
example one of my favorites to to get
people into that is the hook strategy
and the hook strategy is all about
saying how can i use every conversation
every interaction to cast a couple of
hooks to put a couple of interesting
themes into the conversation where the
other person can connect the dots for us
so there's this amazing entrepreneur in
london ollie barrett and if you would
ask olly this kind of dreaded what do
you do question he wouldn't just say i'm
a technology entrepreneur he would say
i'm a technology entrepreneur recently
started reading into the philosophy of
science but what i'm really excited
about is playing the piano and so what
he's doing here is he's giving you three
hooks where you could be like oh my god
such a coincidence my sister is teaching
on the philosophy of science you should
give a guest lecture oh my god such a
coincidence we're hosting piano sessions
you should stop by the point is i'm a
big fan of doing a certain debate
journal where you write down two or
three key themes of you know that's what
i'm curious about at the moment how to
take this idea into curricula or
organizations yada yada and then kind of
you know plug that into conversations
and it's beautiful how often people
would be like
oh my god such a coincidence my brother
of the sister of the father
is xyz right and so but we can't know
this potentiality if we don't put it out
there for people to find it themselves
it is interesting to think about how
people respond to
different situations how would you
characterize
the difference between a person who has
a life which is more lucky and the way
that someone who is less lucky behaves
yeah it's interesting and and
you know if i may i'll start that that
answer with with one of my favorite
experiments which is a bit of a fun
experiment but i think it brings
home that point that a lot of it is how
we frame the world and how we look at
the world and how alert you are to
what's out there and so in this
experiment they um you know took people
who self-identify as very lucky
and and everyone who's listening to this
like i'd love you to think about you
know do you consider yourself to be a
lucky or an unlucky person and just kind
of like then stick with that while while
we talk through that experiment um and
so so they picked people who consider
themselves to be very lucky so people
who say good things tend to happen to me
and and yada yada and then people who
consider themselves to be very unlucky
so people who say bad things tend to
happen to me i'm always in accidents and
so on and we probably all know people in
this kind of continuum
and who are on that now they pick one of
each and they say walk down the street
go into a coffee shop grab a coffee sit
down and then we'll have our
conversation what they don't tell them
is that there's hidden cameras alongside
the street and inside the coffee shop
there's a five pound note some money in
front of the coffee shop door and inside
the coffee shop there's one empty chair
next to this extremely successful
businessman who can make big dreams
happen now the lucky person
walks down the street sees the five
pound note picks it up goes inside the
shop orders the coffee sits next to the
business man they have a conversation
exchange business cards potentially an
opportunity coming out of it we don't
know that part the unlucky person walks
down the street steps over the five
pound note so doesn't see it goes inside
the shop orders the coffee sits next to
the business man ignores the business
man that's it now at the end of the day
they ask both people how was your day
today and so the lucky person says well
it was amazing i found money in the
street made a new friend and you know
potentially an opportunity coming out of
it the unlucky person just says well
nothing really happened and there's a
lot of these kind of experiments where
you can put people into exactly the same
situation and by the way they look at
situations by the way they ask questions
by the way they're alert to opportunity
they will completely differently
experience that and come out lucky or
unlucky i find a lot of money in the
street unfortunately mostly pennies so
it doesn't really help my my lifestyle
that much but i like everyone i would
really highly recommend start looking
for the pennies in the street and you
will continue continuously find them
people drop a lot of money i was
surprised about that by the way so is
the big difference there one person's
more vigilant more observant more open
to new interactions the other person is
more focused less open
less keen about trying to start new
connections
exactly so that's definitely one one of
the factors i mean if you look at it as
kind of like a couple of venn diagrams
that come together to then kind of shape
that that certain dvd mindset one one
piece of this is really this alertness
and and this kind of also often
curiosity right to learn about the world
learn about the environment is the kind
of thing when you know let's say you
take another
way to work in the morning and and
really open your eyes to the street and
see oh there's a bookstore oh that book
in the store people haven't talked about
this for a while that should be a
podcast those kind of things where
serendipity then comes from the most
unexpected of sources books movies
everywhere right everywhere there's
potential dots that we could connect so
so that's definitely a big piece i think
another piece in that experiment was
also around this idea of you know it can
help to actually you know engage people
like like obviously networks social
capital is a huge kind of factor for um
having that potentiality but you know
for closet introverts like myself um
there's a lot of hope that a lot of
times serendipity comes from quiet
sources um like reading a book or that
we can actually work with extroverts
that they kind of do a lot of this for
us so for example going to an event and
speaking about an idea with a host first
so that the host then talks about the
idea things like this where we can
leverage extroverts if we feel more more
introverted
what would you say is the opposite of a
serendipity mindset
i think it's really
someone who
believes that life is given
you know certainly mindset is about the
idea that life is extremely socially
constructed i mean you know there's
there's there's fixed constraints and a
lot of my work is in very kind of
extreme poverty regions and those are
kind of very fixed constraints and and i
think we have to while we work on
mindset also work on these kind of
societal constraints societal
inequalities i think that's a big piece
that goes hand in hand with the mindset
work but then on the mindset side i
think it's someone who doesn't you know
who doesn't question assumptions who in
a way is kind of in this fixed mindset
of of hey look the world is just the way
it is and and you hear that very quickly
in the language people use right when
people use language along the lines of
hey um this is how it's supposed to be
and you know when i look in the stars
like there's this thing that that is
being told to me whatever it is like
that's kind of like more okay i can't
really influence it versus certain
liberty mindset is about i can influence
it i can do something about it
i
hesitate to say that i think british
people might be some of the worst at
creating their own luck and the word
that kept on coming up was cynicism
so someone who's a cynic who would
always presume that this is the way that
things have been this is the way that
things are always going to be that isn't
open to new ideas that isn't questioning
assumptions uh and i don't know whether
that's just the sort of working-class
towns perhaps that i've spent most of my
time in but i kind of get the impression
that it's not and i'm out here in austin
texas at the moment
very much you know i was walking out of
the sauna a couple of days ago and one
dude went hey man um i think i think i
know you from your podcast what are you
doing tomorrow night i was like i don't
know that was last night uh and he's
like i've just moved into a new ranch
i'll give you a message on instagram if
you want to come up and we'll put a fire
on and you can meet some new friends and
last night i made five new friends
because this guy decided that that's not
that's never once happened to me in the
uk that sort of openness it would be
significantly more cynical
rolling it back to what you said before
charlie hooper guy that does charisma on
command which is this huge five and a
half million subscriber youtube channel
um one of the questions that he gets
asked when he's coaching people on
charisma is how to have a better open
and how to make yourself feel more
interesting and see more interesting to
people and one of his best things is to
do exactly what you said with the hook
strategy so he is trying to put out a
number of different points of contact
that people could get themselves on so i
live in la at the moment i run my own
business but i've traveled the world for
a very long time i actually coach people
on charisma i once met russell brand and
i can play the piano or some [ __ ] like
that right and that all of those
different opportunities there again it's
the opposite of a cynic mindset of just
saying oh my name's charlie and i do
stuff on the internet like who's who's
excited or interested by that person and
i think
you kind of suggested that especially
with introverts
there's like a first mover problem here
right who is it that's going to actually
begin the momentum within this
interaction and if someone enters the
frame and makes it kind of
fun and exciting and banterful and
you're able to go back and forth it's
easier for you because you bounce off
their energy but it is really just a
tiny little flick of an avalanche at the
top and then it just cascades from there
so i do think even though i i would also
agree relatively introverted myself
i do think that it doesn't take much to
just program into you a little script
that you can run that kind of sets the
tone and then that person's energy
increases and you bounce off that and
their energy increases and you bounce
off that
and yeah you know the people that are
like that you know the people that when
you sit down
in the sauna or at a coffee shop or at a
party or something that you go yeah i
want to talk to that person more because
they made me feel energized and they
weren't cynical so yeah i think the
opposite of a serendipity mindset is
cynicism as far as i can see well that's
really interesting right to exactly your
point i mean one thing that i found
extremely helpful as someone you know
who
you know we live in a world designed for
kind of more extroverted people and then
kind of like we try to make the best of
it right and have spikes of extroversion
everyone thinks you're an extrovert but
actually then you're hiding in the
toilet after the speech and so it's kind
of those things where
where those kind of things happen and so
what i like there's two things i found
extremely helpful in that regard one is
to think about questions beforehand so
you know if you would ever run into that
conference speaker or that potential
lovely life or something else you have
one or two questions that feel authentic
to to yourself and that feel oh this i
could literally ask everyone i could
literally ask everyone what do you enjoy
doing right instead of what do you do
which puts someone into a box if i
slightly change it into what do you
enjoy doing the other person can can can
veer into whatever area they want and i
think you had a great point there on
energy right then then they get out of
their autopilot in terms of i'm this i'm
this i'm this too i actually enjoy this
and this and this where then you can
pick up on whatever is most most
interesting i think the second point you
know is really when you think about what
holds us back a lot of times what are
the kind of fears that that that are
there you know is it imposter syndrome
there's always this kind of small little
imposter in there or fear of rejection
things like this something that i found
extremely helpful is to think about
what's the worst thing that can happen
like i always thought the worst thing
that can happen is rejection right
conference speaker saying i don't have
time for you i love interest saying i
don't find you interesting whatever it
is but then i realized that sting of
rejection is nothing in comparison to
this feeling of ah what could have
happened had i spoken with a person that
feeling of regret that feeling of like
thinking the whole day oh if i had done
this could could this and this happen
it's very mark twain thing in terms of
that you would regret the things you you
haven't done over the things that you
have and and so i think it's very much
this kind of thing of of really
reframing it away from hey rejection is
really the thing that's that's the worst
here to hey the worst thing that can
happen is to not act on it and then
feel really bad about it that is the
best takeaway that i had from your work
the fact that the pain of
not closing a loop and the pain of a
what if is way way way worse than the
pain of rejection especially if you can
add a tiny bit of humor into it because
if someone does like reject you in a
rude way you it's it's funnier than it
is rude but the worst sort of rejection
isn't the one that's really rude yet
it's the one that you've got in your
mind and yeah perfect example the first
weekend that i landed here in austin in
november last year
uh tim ferriss right
god of the podcasting world one of the
ogs uh was in the sauna cold plunge
place that i go to and he went in with
somebody that i know right so a past
podcaster i guess dr dan engel owns that
place dan knows me
tim ferriss walks in i'm like right okay
i know dan i don't know tim i'd love to
know tim tim's right there
we went in came back out and then tim
was sat down reading a book and i just
thought i won't i won't interrupt him
he's reading his book and he's doing
whatever and now
even now three and a half months on i
could have just gone up and said hey man
i just wanted to let you know you did a
how to start a podcast podcast four
years ago that i listened to were now 50
million plays deep i just wanted to say
thank you for the stuff that you've done
what's that 10 seconds
10 seconds and
tim ferriss is no way that big of a dick
that he wouldn't have at least been
accepting of it if not like genuinely
happy to feel like because i'd i'd like
to feel that right or hear that from
someone
but i didn't do it and it still plagues
me to this day that still hangs over me
versus had i have just gone up and
tapped him on the arm and said hey man
thank you for everything that you do and
blah blah blah blah blah and who knows
what would have come out of that so i
don't have i don't have many regrets but
that that from the last couple of months
is one that sticks with me
yeah no i feel you and i think that's
exactly you know when you think about it
in terms of
it
now it's at least also a good story
right either way like everything that if
even if it would have been rejection
right it would have been a good story
and so the point is like to like i'm
i've actually become a big fan of
rejection in the sense of it feels
really bad in the moment
but it literally closes other doors
right so the rejection of you know that
love interest where you thought oh my
god this is the love of my life and then
you realizing actually she's like a bit
of a you know um that might be great if
you would have figured that out in five
years once you're married and have two
kids it's a bit too light right
and you know that's what i found really
fascinating in terms of when does
something become the inflection point
for something and that actually a lot of
times serendipity comes out of crisis it
comes out of you know something not
working out some kind of rejection for a
job and then you're like oh my god i
could actually open up my own business
and or my own cool podcast or whatever
it is right versus so so maybe you know
tim ferriss would have said hey do this
for me and then it would have ended up
as like a medium type whatever thing
versus now you have your own big thing
you know what i mean so it's kind of i
feel almost hey great maybe that was
also the best it's almost like you know
um it could become infection points
either way but i think um that a lot of
times serendipity actually comes out of
crises or it comes out of things that
didn't work and rejection is a big one
there i guess
there's a concept that i bro scienced
into existence called anxiety cost so
you understand opportunity cost right
that by doing one thing you can't do
another anxiety cost to me is
the amount of time that you spend
thinking about an unclosed loop
so that is a cost that you could have
fixed had you have just done the thing
had i have gone up and spoken to tim
ferriss it would have taken me 20
seconds to walk across the room 10
seconds to speak to him 30 seconds total
time investment as opposed to probably
hours that i've reflected on that
situation or the same thing that i need
to go to the gym today if you go to the
gym in the morning that means that for
the rest of the day you can bathe in
your self-congratulatory adulation and
feel all prestigious because you went to
the gym earlier as opposed to leaving it
until 8 p.m and you spent all of the day
thinking to yourself i've got to go to
the gym i've got to go to the gym i've
got to go to the gym
and
yeah i think that trying to limit that
by just putting yourself into situations
is such an easier
way to do that and remembering the pain
of unfulfilled what-ifs is way worse
than the pain of rejection for no matter
how introverted you are that's a pretty
big motivator
absolutely and i love the way you frame
that i think that's a very quotable
sentence
right there
what about different types of
serendipity there must be different
categories of some kind
yeah well it's interesting because in a
way when you think about what is
certainly all about it's a lot of times
there's three different types that that
we found now work one is that you're
saying you're already looking for
something let's say you're looking for a
job at you know exposed consultancy and
then you coincidentally run into someone
that you didn't expect could even help
you with this and they get you that job
so in a way you already knew what you
wanted but you find a very kind of
unexpected way to to get there i mean
you know the quintessential
example there's archimedes who you know
he for his uh for his king he tried to
figure out like is that crown real gold
or did someone kind of you know mess
with the king and so he didn't find a
solution to this and so he went you know
chilled out in the baths right the kind
of uh in a way the the old version of
the of the sauna it seems like good
things happen there right that's
fantastic and so he went to the he went
to the bath and he lowered himself into
the water and he realized oh wow like
the water will be pushed differently
depending on the weight of something and
so essentially if i do that with a crown
i can i can figure out if that is real
gold and so he he already knew what he
would what he wanted to do but he found
an unexpected way to solve that now
that's the first piece the second piece
is really when you kind of like you're
not looking for anything right and then
boom thunderbolts happens and you know
you sit in that coffee shop you weren't
looking for love but you instantly know
that is the person and then you know it
kind of like happens in that moment and
and develops from there so it's kind of
you're not looking for anything but it
happens and then the third piece is
really more the kind of posted notes
type serenity where you're looking for
something maybe you're looking for a job
in consulting and then you get that job
and you realize oh i actually don't
really want it but on the way you
realize you know one of the people who
interviewed you could be an amazing
co-founder for your business and so you
start something completely different so
you look for something but then you find
something completely different in the
process like post-it notes right they
looked for a stronger glue but then
realized oh wow a weaker glue might be
it might be much cooler than that and so
the point is what they all have in
common is there's always some kind of
unexpected moment right something that
that happens but then again we have to
do something and connect the dots and
and and act on it
one of the problems that i had was with
people who say things happen for a
reason so they look back after some
catastrophe that they've gone through
and they say well yeah but this this
happened for a reason i broke my legs
for a reason i crashed my car for a
reason i lost my job for a reason the
reason that i don't like that wording is
that it seems to me to take the agency
out of that person's
actions right that
okay let's say that in one version of
the universe this did happen for a
reason and you were meant to get into a
car crash and you were meant to break
your legs and you were meant to lose
your job right and then out of the back
of that you've now got a better life
the other version of the story which i
believe is that
something shitty happened to you three
times like car crash broken legs lost
your job and you overcame that you went
through all of these different
situations and you made something good
come out of something bad or you made
something great come out of something
good you know i had this great
opportunity and then i became whatever
it is i wanted or i found my wife or i
did whatever right that to me is a much
more
empowering inspiring
energizing story to tell yourself then
like what what's the old what does what
do people mean when they say
this happened for a reason you're like
post hoc rationalizing all of the good
stuff you did and outsourcing it to what
like some higher power
[ __ ] that like it's your you were the
person that made this
go well so i don't it feels very
disempowering to me when people say that
and it feels like it's kind of like the
serendipity mindset or connect the dots
as well that you're kind of reverse
engineering
your own input into this situation out
of it and leaving it completely up to
chance
well that's the interesting thing right
that if you think about it and you know
it reminds me of this this beautiful
idea that does the situation define you
or do you define the situation right so
in a way you know most inspiring people
that i know had some kind of inflection
points in their life where the question
was will that situation define them will
they be the one who was broken up with
for the rest of their life will be the
one will they be the one who was
bankrupt for the rest of their life
right so do they do they settle with
that idea that something went wrong or
do they say no this becomes the
inflection point for something and now i
find something better or something that
that fits better and so i think that's
the fascinating thing right and it
always reminds me um
that kind of agency and that comes
really back to to to the social
constructedness of things it reminds me
of viktor frankl and um you know he
wrote this amazing book man search for
meaning uh i read it when i had uh
actually two near-death experiences i i
reread it recently um but so i've been
reading it and and what i've always
found inspiring when he kind of you know
he was in a concentration camp which as
you can imagine or in several but like
as you can imagine that's the toughest
situation you can be in
objectively there's no hope no meaning
nothing it's objectively meaningless
from the perspective of the person who's
in there and in general from a societal
uh
perspective and and so it's kind of the
toughest situation you can be in and he
said you know what i still have agency
in this situation even in this most of
meaningless situations i will create
meaning and so what he did was he was
saying look every day i will still speak
with another prisoner in this camp to
make them feel better and by doing this
now i have a meaning to wake up tomorrow
morning now i have a reason to wake up
tomorrow morning because i still have to
talk with so many people to make them
feel better and then i also still want
to write that book once i get out of
here and so what he did was he created
this duality of meaning of a day-to-day
meaning where every day there was a bit
of a small meaning and then also this
big meaning hey this is still something
i want to do when when i'm out of here
and i've always found that inspiring is
this idea that look if victor frankel
can do this in a concentration camp if
social entrepreneurs can do that in
sub-saharan africa where a lot of our
work is i think we can do that in a lot
of other contexts as well and so i think
there's always this huge element i think
of hey what is our agency here and what
can we do with it and can we define that
situation a little bit
what were you doing in africa
well so i started working there around
10 years ago um
but you know first for my phd which was
all around the question of how do
entrepreneurs in that context develop
their networks to somehow have an impact
and and and to scale and to grow and um
it's become you know for me
the context where i've learned the most
from in the sense of especially kenya
and south africa i will never forget for
example the first time i i went there
and now very good friend of mine i asked
him so so me as someone coming to your
context what should i never ask you
what's the one thing that you know these
white kids coming into your contacts
always ask you but like you should never
and never do that and he said don't ask
me what i need as a first question if
you would if you ask me what i need as a
first question you put me into the role
of the victim of the beneficiary of
someone who kind of needs your
benevolence because if you come in and
say what's here what can we do together
and then you can still like resource and
whatever but we then kind of meet on the
same level and i think that to me was
extremely inspiring because i think you
know when i think about all these
development efforts over the last
decades a lot of them have failed
because there's always this idea of oh
people just need better nutrition and
better education no people also need
dignity and hope on the feeling that
they can create their own luck and that
you create like that you don't give them
handouts and i think that's kind of for
me there was a big shift in thinking to
say no it's not just about lower needs
and fulfilling them first it's starting
with meaning it's starting with dignity
and and then kind of getting from there
and i think that for me has informed
everything else i've been doing
what
role have you what's the framework that
you've got in that case for
reframing
things you know we've spoken about
victor frankl we've spoken about people
in sub-saharan africa but you know being
in a really shitty situation and just
manifesting meaning
seems like a pretty big task so have you
got some steps that people can go
through
yeah that's a great question and again
you know i would never
like i i
i lived in this context for a little bit
as a kind of guest but i would never you
know i think both from the inside and
from the outside you know there's
objectively resource constraints and we
have to work on them and i think that's
a given so so that's not what i'm
talking about what i'm talking about
though is that in every context you find
people who have a different mindset than
than other people in in the same context
and so in this context for example
there's this amazing organization that
used an approach that i find extremely
useful in those kind of contexts which
is scaling bricolage so scaling the
making the best out of what is at hand
so what they do is it's a organization
that has a low-cost education
methodology so you know it's things like
10 steps to use social media to build a
business and stuff like that and what
they do is they go into other low-income
communities and instead of asking what
do you need because they don't have
resources that they could give
and and that's obviously not the
approach they want to use they say
what's already here and how can we make
the best out of this there's an old
garage fantastic that could be a
training center there's a former drug
dealer fantastic that person has amazing
resourcefulness probably they probably
have a lot of social capital and if you
turn them into a teacher they can
probably turn the whole community around
and so the point here is that you're
looking at the world from the
perspective of what can we make with
what's here versus what we think we need
and that kind of like you can transfer
right they've used that model in banks
for example where the old school
approach during the pandemic would be we
have to fire people because we don't
have the resources now to have them sit
in the office or have them sit at home
or stuff like that that's always the
easy way out right to fire people to
calling for decreased costs with this
kind of scaling bricolage model the idea
is that you go in and you say okay
what's already here we have this cashier
and we don't need them because we have a
machine for that now well but maybe that
could be a financial trainer and maybe
the office could be the broadcast center
for the online financial education
course and so the point here is that
once you reframe it away from what do we
need we need more budget more resources
to what's already here how do we make
the best of it you can create budgets
around this right where you ask people
hey have you already considered how you
could use the chairs of your neighboring
restaurant for your event rather than
needing 10 shares to buy and stuff like
that and then once you do that you get
so used to this idea oh actually there's
always resources around us if we see it
or not and that comes back to the
serendipity mindset that there's an
abundance of potentiality but we tend to
not see it because we're so focused on
particular resources and particular
things
what do you think it is about the
when you're not looking for it that's
when it arrives mentality to do with
luck you know that buses you're waiting
and waiting and then when you finally
turn away that's when the bus arrives
type thing i think you know it's
commonly held wisdom have you ever seen
this arise inside of your own work at
all when people start focusing on things
less somehow opportunities arise too
because that seems to run quite counter
to what we're talking about one of these
is
deliberateness intentionality whereas
that is almost
i don't know like turn your back and
forget about it and then it's gonna
happen
yeah well look and i think um you know
those thunderbolt kind of serendipitous
happen a lot of times that when you're
not looking for anything and then that
beautiful thing happens where you fall
in love and and xyz things like this and
and i think you know to me that comes a
lot back to the point of am i trying too
hard for something if i if i want this
one job in this one consultancy and i'm
trying really hard that can be really
great but i might also close my eyes now
to all these other potential
consultancies or to all these
conversations randomly next to me where
someone was talking about that they're
looking for exactly the person that i am
but i didn't even listen to it is that
what you think the problem with wanting
stuff too hard or trying too hard is
then that you become
overly narrow focused
exactly and i think what it creates is
anxiety right a lot of anxiety i mean i
remember i used to be very much like
this like hey i need a plan i want to
know exactly what i'll map out in xyz
and then i had this amazing mentor and
he always used to tell me christian
people like you always think there's one
way to roam and then you realize you
don't even want to be in rome and and to
me that kind of like really drove it
home where you're like geez like you
think you know what you want you think
you know what it is
you know nothing to your point earlier
we're all just winging it like how can i
know now what i want in 10 years like
how is that even possible i don't know
you know i i know you know i have a
beautiful family and things like this
but you know we might kind of like
whatever kind of like life kind of
happens it happens in terms of you know
we'll find another city to live in
whatever whatever you never know what
happens the point is that i think
you know from our work and and i the the
inner research in me comes out when when
you ask that question the nerdy one
who says we just did a study actually
with with ceos where we tried to figure
out what is it that makes the most
successful ceos really successful and
the one key theme that they all have in
common is that they're extremely good at
saying here's a sense of direction if
i'm running mastercard here is my sense
of direction we want to get 500 million
people into the financial system who
were previously unbanked this is our
north star this is our sense of
direction here's an approximate strategy
but i'm already telling you now that we
will adjust that strategy based on your
information coming in so what they do is
they they give people a sense of clarity
of where we're going but at the same
time also build the unexpected as part
of the plan and i think that to me in my
own life and in the lives of others i've
seen that that decreases anxiety so much
because you're saying yes i have a key
sense of direction but i'm also open to
the unexpected and even if i don't i
work a lot with young people and young
people there's so much pressure on them
in terms of find your purpose find your
meaning find this and this
i mean come on when you're 18 years old
like how are you supposed to do all that
so i'm a big fan actually of asking them
what's your curiosity right what is what
is something that really you're curious
about and then that becomes your sense
of direction for a time and then
something else becomes and then you more
and more go towards the sense that that
who you are and who you want to be in
this world but i think as long as we
don't know that i think a key curiosity
gives us a sense of direction without
over pressuring that plan i think that's
to your point if we get too rigid with a
plan that's when things go wrong well as
soon as you have that plan especially
one that's rigid you then begin to
measure the difference between where you
are and where the plan said that you
were and inherent in that is that
there's going to be some anxiety around
however far away from it you are and
then over time this is going to diverge
yeah i am
i don't know i think that that sort of
flexible approach
would
implicit in that the subtext of having
that flexible approach is that
you can be more confident that future
you will deal with whatever problems
arise like the reason that you have an
unbelievably strictly laid out plan is
basically because of a lack of faith
that you could come up with a solution
impromptu now and now and now and now
and now
so
by having a more flexible plan that
empowers the people who are following
the direction to say well look like you
know we knew that this was going to be a
thing they're constantly being more
vigilant because they know that they're
actually on the lookout for new
opportunities and generally i think i
have this friend who's uh
spends way too much money on supercars
and he always says that um when he buys
another one i have faith that future
andrew will pay for it
and the point is that
he believes in himself so much that it
doesn't matter he's like i'll spend the
money now and the guy tomorrow will end
up paying for it now i am aware that
some people have probably got themselves
into some pretty severe credit card debt
by also taking that point of view but he
has evidence as well over time that he's
accumulated that shows him that he's
probably going to be quite okay but yeah
i think um
i think taking a looser approach
heading towards some sort of a north
star
rough hewn on the way up there
i think that that's
a pretty good way to go about it well
and the interesting thing is to your
point right if if that's kind of being
hand in hand with a kind of measured
risk-taking approach right to your point
versus like over confidence maybe that
some people kind of in in some some ways
might do um you know that's kind of like
i think what's fascinating about when
you look at successful people and you
study them
what always kind of is with them is that
they
you know to give an example i was
fascinated when covet happened and when
covet happened you know you had all
these old school leaders and the old
school leadership mantra is always
portray strength always portray that you
know everything that that you have
everything under control so it's a
complete illusion of control and and
some people buy it some people don't but
but in a way it's completely lying to
everyone right and so you know when
covet happened you had this kind of in
the u.s here um you had some governors
or some kind of people who are running
the state essentially saying
here's an exact timeline on when we open
up here's exactly what we'll do here's
exactly when like xyz will happen now
when new information comes in of course
now they have to either revise the
timeline and look weak or they have to
hide the data which a lot of them did
right the other the new school
leadership approach um that's based on
that kind of more the mindset we've been
talking about is to say hey here's our
kind of north star here's our sense of
direction which is public health and
economic health here's an approximate
timeline based on these kind of things
the timeline is usually then the same as
with the other that's the funny thing
right it's the same timeline they will
both give but they will say
we already tell you now as soon as new
information comes in we will revise the
timeline and that will be part of our
plan and by doing this now when new
information comes in and they revise the
timeline they look strong versus the
other ones looking weak and to me that's
the big difference this is really not
about at all saying let's let go of
everything and like let's let's kind of
just be out there and float no this is
actually being realistic about what you
can control and then controlling
everything you can control but then also
letting go of the solution of control
and i think that's where it gets
exciting because then to your point
you don't get anxious about new data
because that wasn't part of your plan
because you said when new information
comes in will adjust
are you familiar with the control
problem in artificial general
intelligence have you heard about this
i did but but please i mean yeah okay so
there's a an issue that a misaligned
super intelligent agi that is given some
optimization function could end up
turning the entire world into paper
clips because it didn't realize that we
didn't quite mean don't turn everybody
into paper clips and one of the um
solutions that's proposed is kind of
similar to what you're saying it's
called machine extrapolated volition
right mev
and what it proposes is that instead of
trying to create in advance a bunch of
rules which cover every single potential
misinterpretation of every rule and it
somehow manages to quantify in code what
we mean by good and happy and human and
life and
everything else right which we already
can't define even just using words
instead what it says is that
you ask the machine
to come up with its own solution for
what we would have wanted had we have
known as much as it knows right so it's
this ever
mutating ever progressing ever updating
solution it's constantly checking
against what we would have asked for had
we known what it knows which is way way
more than we know
and it kind of feels a little bit like
the malleable
uh easy to move
plan that you're saying the sort of new
wave of politicians and business leaders
are following it's kind of similar to
that we're not trying to say in advance
exactly what we're going to do we're
going to have a plan which is going to
be updated on root and we know that it's
going to be more optimal because it's
going to be able to adjust to things
that we couldn't see like maybe a global
pandemic and it's going to make us look
stronger because in advance we said that
this was what we were going to do
well this is i mean that's that's a
fascinating um theme right because um
and by the way those of you interested
in this there's um the the the weltecon
reform they have these knowledge maps
which is essentially ai kind of building
interest graphs and knowledge graphs and
kind of like trying to like ai trying to
figure out how do we how do we organize
your knowledge differently than than
kind of traditional things did and i've
always found that super interesting in
terms of what can i do and and how how's
that being organized but to your point
something that
it's beautifully serendipitous that you
that that you brought that up we
actually just finished a very nerdy
paper those of you just delighted to
share um about exactly what is the role
of ai in serendipity like how do we
you know when you think about the
relationship between ai and serendipity
how does that interplay and and one of
the key kind of like conclusions we came
to was that like like like ai is
extremely good at to your point once you
have a certain idea of
you know criteria of judgment like
something that you're saying okay this
is what we think we might want or
something like this here's a couple of
criteria of judgement and then let them
run with it extremely good right at
getting all the information in all this
stuff but then serendipity a lot of
times depends on meaning making right it
depends on sense making it depends on
this kind of social context it depends
on you know ai can try to find me my
love my life but then i have to still
have that gut feel of yes this could be
it versus not right and so that's the
fascinating thing where this
augmentation between ai and the human
actually can then scale serendipitous
innovation by saying
ai can scale the information it can
scale the potential data point and
recommend some stuff and then human
meaning making can kind of like connect
a couple of those dots and then if you
take that together you can actually
scale that up and i think that's where
these knowledge graphs become extremely
interesting where you can then
potentially get more information quicker
but also connect the dots much quicker
as well but i think that's at the very
beginning of um and i'm certainly i'm
i'm a student of this i'm still kind of
trying to learn how this is playing out
it's a fascinating theme dude read super
intelligence by nick bostrom or probably
audible it because the the book is a
little bit of a heavy meal
but that's that came out in 2014 or 2016
i think maybe 2014 and it's a new york
times bestseller hardcore
ai existential risk understanding the
different types of takeoffs so the way
that i have no idea how it became a new
york times bestseller but obviously
because it's very well written and
really engaging right but it shouldn't
do given that the topic that it's about
um
but that was that really informed a lot
of my understanding about ai systems but
also
the principles that underpin them and
machine extrapolated volition is such a
useful tool just to have
even if you're not thinking about
designing an ai which obviously i'm not
but
it's just a really useful thing way to
think about having an adaptive plan that
moves forward and allowing cumulative
wisdom to feed back into whatever it is
that you want
wasn't there a thing didn't you do
something to do with rabbits ears wasn't
that in the book the floppiness of
rabbit's ears oh yes yes yes yeah yeah
yeah yeah what was that yeah yeah well
that's actually you know that's a
beautiful example actually of
of counterfactuals right which i think
is always the fascinating thing what
could have happened had you acted on
something right the beautiful
conversation we had earlier about that
kind of thing of like ah had i gone
through with this next was that and so
the floppy rabbits is really about this
idea that two researchers at the same
time
gave kind of rabbits some kind of
injection um you know testing something
and then the the rabbit's ears flopped
and and and both of them were surprised
so both of them had the same random
surprising
observation but only one of them acted
on it and you know realized oh my god
that's about blood flow that's about
kind of like you know accelerating blood
flow and so on so he kind of helped turn
that into arthritis kind of tackling
medication and became like got a lot of
prices versus the other one didn't do
anything with it and so it's the
fascinating thing right what we talked
about in the coffee shop that our
reaction to that unexpected moment then
that's what makes it it's yes it's
random but then hey what do we do with
it
so we've got the
serendipity journal
we've got the hook strategy what else
what are some other ways that people can
apply
what we've gone through today to try and
get a bit more luck in their lives
well like i i had two near-death
experiences in life so i'm i'm a huge
fan of actually trying to not have
native experiences in your life but to
actually have the same logic that a lot
of people like me have when you face
death which is
you just don't care about a lot of
things anymore because you're like you
know what when you're on your deathbed
you won't care about if you have four or
five cars in your garage
and you won't care about so many things
you think you care about now um and i'm
a big fan of um you know i would
literally google um deathbed regrets
where there's a nurse that wrote down
the kind of top bad regrets of people
who who she had on
on her death beds and it's always the
same things right it's always i wish
they had lived a life uh truer to myself
i wish i had spent more time with the
people i love and more meaningful
connections with them and stuff like
that and so i think to me this is really
at the absolute core of everything we
just talked about serendipity is about
potentiality it's about who we could be
who others could be and one thing that
can really help us figure this out is to
become clear about who who do i want to
be what are the kind of being at values
being a kind of non-negotiable values
that that i feel i want to stand for so
when i'm on my deathbed that's what i
will be happy about while i be proud of
so i'm a big fan of this kind of
primordium where you're essentially
saying okay how do i think about now
what i would regret on my deathbed if i
would run in front of a car tomorrow and
i think to me this comes to a bigger
point chris which is i think we always
assume you know there's a lot of times
to still you know do the things that
feel really meaningful so for example a
lot of my students they first go into a
job that they don't enjoy that much
because it gives them a lot of money and
networks and then later on they do the
things they really care about and one
conversation we have a lot is that yes
like by any means like if you have
student debt and everything else you got
to do something to pay that back and at
the same time don't assume that you have
a lot of time like don't assume that you
know life might not be over very quickly
so try to do as much as you can now that
actually gives you something meaningful
so if you join xyz bank by any means
find out on day one if there's a board
member who's excited about similar
issues as you are and can you then get
that bank to tackle those issues or
something like this where you leverage
them as a platform then towards what
you're really excited about and build
that meaning into it and i think that
comes back to our earlier point that
even in those situations where some
people might say oh i have to work in
this bank now for five years before i
can do x was it no try to figure out
within this bank if you can somehow
develop leverage a lot of times it's
interns who built the most meaningful
stuff by finding a couple of people a
couple of champions and then um within
the organization then do something
really meaningful and so i think it's
really about um you know going on our
deathbed and saying what would i regret
and then thinking from from there what's
meaningful to us and trying to find the
people who feel meaningful to us i think
to your point right what are the kind of
communities that feel meaningful to us
uh the kind of themes and and so on
there's a guy alex hormozy who's coming
on the show next month and he recently
sold his business for some insane amount
of money and he put a tweet out the
other day that said stop saying that 50
years old is middle-aged the average
life expectancy of a man in the united
states is
75.5 years old he said 37 years old
is middle-aged
you have way less time than you think
and that's back to your point right that
you do kind of need to remember that the
clock ticks down to death it doesn't
take up from birth
that's the way that's the way that your
life is going there is a limited number
of
books that you get to read for the rest
of your life there are a limited number
of netflix shows and
meals out with friends and
time that you get to spend with your
parents and time you get to spend with
your kid and so on and so forth
you need to make sure that you use them
right and a lot of the time if you if
you haven't done that pre-mortem if you
haven't looked at
what is the direction that i want to go
in perfect to what you said earlier on
you think that you want to go to rome
and halfway along the journey you
realize that you that wasn't even the
place that you were supposed to end up
at
and yeah
going through life
to find out
not only that you didn't mean to get
there but that you wanted to be
somewhere else as well
that's a that's a a pretty dangerous
situation to be in so yeah i uh i hope
that that has scared some people into
into realizing they should probably do a
little bit of reassessment
well and to your point right i feel it's
fascinating once you then face death i
think steve jobs says it beautifully
right that like of course emotionally
like in those kind of situations when he
he got cancer right he he had this
beautiful um sentence that the death can
be life's greatest motivator right
imagine a situation where if you would
live forever right
i mean what kind of sense of urgency
would you feel what kind of sense of
meaning would you feel when you know
yeah whatever i do like i'll still be
here in like 50 000 years so whatever
right versus like now that you know
actually i only have a limited amount of
time maybe that also can be meaningful
in that sense and so i actually um you
know i spent a lot of times um after my
first and second native experience with
people who have cancer for example and
other terminal diseases and what i found
fascinating is how many of them
have then found a deep purpose so for
example taken the cancer and say this
will be a campaign now and i'll run this
like i ran a campaign in politics or xyz
and i will inform others about how we
can go about this and and you know set
up a foundation on it you name it and so
the point is that i think it's it's kind
of hopefully it never comes to kind of
those things right terminal disease and
so which obviously is the worst thing
that can happen and at the same time i
think this question of how do we think
about that yes lime life life can be
short but also maybe that's not a bad
thing in the sense that it can give us
meaning to actually focus now on the
things that are truly meaningful and and
then you know i don't know if you're
watching i just started watching this
the show now i'm forgetting the name but
it's all about this kind of upload um
where essentially people then get
digitally uploaded and then they
download again and it's just a
fascinating kind of whole whole thing i
forgot the name of it but my point is
who knows what happens afterwards right
who knows what what comes next so let's
make the best of what we can do here
dr christian bush ladies and gentlemen
if people want to keep up to date with
what you do where should they go
so the home page is the
serendipitymindset.com um i'm at
chrisserndip on twitter and uh the book
is in bookstores around the world thanks
mate i appreciate you
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace